okay so at the end of last week we
looked at a clip of new Trump lawyer
Rudy Giuliani mr. 9/11 former New York
City Mayor telling Sean Hannity on FOX
News that yes
despite Donald Trump's countless claims
that he neither knew about the hundred
and thirty thousand dollar hush money
payment to adult film actress stormy
Daniels nor that he paid Michael Cohen
back for the hundred and thirty thousand
dollars Rudy Giuliani showed up and he
said yeah Trump paid back the hundred
and thirty grand to Michael Cohen and
it's all fine quick reminder from last
week just to get us reset here I was
talking about the hundred thirty
thousand dollar payment right the
settlement payment which is a very
regular thing for lawyers to do the
question there was the only possible
violation there would be was it a
campaign finance violation but usually
we result in a fine by the way not this
big storm of storm troopers coming in
and breaking down his apartment and
breaking out his office that was money
that was paid by by his lawyer the way I
would do out of his law firm funds or
whatever funds doesn't matter the
president reimbursed that over a period
of seven he it said didn't I distinctly
remember that he did it on his own he
did without asking look I don't know I
haven't investigated that no reason to
dispute that no reason industry with
recollection I like Michael a lot you
like Michael a long time I feel very bad
he's been victimized like this the
president feels even worse
well not lot that long after this
interview Donald Trump was asked about
it and he straight-up told reporters
that Rudy was going to get his facts
straight soon and the next day Rudy
Giuliani walked back to comment sort of
been in a totally unintelligible way and
Rudy Giuliani's new position is outlined
in a short written statement he put out
which we're gonna put up on the screen
for you and the statement starts by
saying this is intended to clarify the
views I expressed over the past few days
the statement only makes them less clay
it clear first he says there is no
campaign violation the payment was made
to resolve a personal and false
allegation in order to protect the
president's family it would have been
done in any event whether he was a
candidate or not hard to believe second
he says my references to timing were not
describing my understanding of the
president's knowledge but
instead my understanding of these
matters completely unintelligible
statement and number three it is
undisputed that the president's
dismissal of former director Comey was
clearly within his article to power
recent revelations about former director
Comey further confirmed the wisdom of
the president's decision which was
plainly in the best interest of our
nation so let's focus on that middle one
if we can put it back up for a moment
that middle one Rudy Giuliani says my
references to timing were not describing
my understanding of the president's
knowledge but instead my understanding
of these matters so it sounds like what
he's kind of saying is I don't even know
I mean it's like it's a it's a statement
insofar as I recognize all of those
words his words that are part of the
English language and they seem to be
arranged in the form of a sentence I
don't know what he was attempting to
communicate basically saying what he
said to Hannity was his interpretation
not not what Trump believes to be the
circumstance I'm so confused I'm
starting to question if I am the sane
one reading me I know what you mean
right and and it's like do we believe
that this is some incredible 4d chess
move right admitting to the payment and
then kind of walking it back but in a
linguistic linguistically unintelligible
way like what is what chess game is that
move a part of and if it's simply to
make Trump appear to be an unreliable
witness to mitigate future problems if
he's eventually interviewed by robert
muller doesn't seem like a good legal
strategy so I'm back to applying Trump's
razor right I've mentioned this before
Occam's razor is a principle that
basically suggests if you have two
explanations for the same thing the
simpler one is usually better or more
accurate right when you need to make
more assumptions to have a coherent
explanation that's usually an inferior
assumption you go with the simp and
inferior explanation you go with the
simpler one that's Occam's razor
Trump's razor is if you have two
competing explanations for an occurrence
related to the Trump administration the
one that implies the stupidest behavior
by Trump and his cronies is the one you
go with so here it's that the admission
of the hundred and thirty K payment and
then the walk back is not like a
carefully crafted thing to portray a
particular impression it's just that
these people are incompetent so Trump's
razor if
Lyde here would suggest that we go with
incompetence and the real explanation is
more than likely Giuliani accidentally
told the truth because he wasn't aware
that he was supposed to be lying about
everything like Trump does and then
Trump called them out or something like
that
and big picture I've mentioned the
debate tactic called the Gish Gallup
where you just throw out a ton of
overwhelming inaccuracies during a
debate and then your opponent can't
really refute them one by one
what Trump's team does is similar it's
called the firehose of falsehoods it's a
Russian propaganda tactic you just put
out tons of conflicting statements with
no regard for the truth no consistency
just one statement after another and
then the public basically becomes
conditioned to distrust number one any
reporting about you and number two to
not hold you accountable for lies it has
almost no downside so whether it's
calculated or not this might actually
work very very much in Trump's favor if
you haven't joined stitcher premium yet
now is the perfect time stitcher premium
gets you completely ad free episodes of
hundreds of shows like comedy bang bang
WTF with Marc Maron and how did this get
made
you also get 21,000 hours of exclusive
content including originals like
Marvel's Wolverine and it's arrays fruit
which are launching every week for
stitcher premium members if you love
podcasts and obviously you do you were
missing out when you listen to ad free
episodes in stitcher premium your
favorite podcasters get paid help
support your favorite shows and join
stitcher Premium today and for a free
month of listening go to stitcher
Premium calm and use the promo code
Pakman PA KMA n